hoover
max extract pressure pro model 60
over
pressure
model 60.
hey guys pete here we're at the end of
the road once a week since episode 609
aired i've been saying that i don't know
what will happen next and that i think
it's a great place to be today i'll do
that one last time and honestly even as
i'm saying that it doesn't feel real in
just a few days we'll know how the story
of jimmy mcgill and kim wexler ends and
say goodbye to the breaking bad universe
for the foreseeable future we have a
title a teaser and some promo photos for
episode 13 to discuss so if any of that
sounds like spoilers then this is your
chance to leave and without out of the
way let's get into it i don't know about
you but i want to see some death this is
born out of the expectations involved
with something i love coming to an end
and better call saul is that it's just a
tv show but it matters for all the time
i've invested in these characters and
their stories i feel like i've gotten
something back and so on some level the
ending can't change that and either way
i trust the creatives involved to
deliver something that is at least
thought provoking and entertaining but
that doesn't mean there aren't some
things i want to see happen as we head
into the 13th and final episode there
are only two questions left to answer
what happens to jimmy and what happens
to kim these are very different
questions from what happens to jimmy and
kim as dropping the and convention from
the titles after 609 points out jimmy
and kim is something that only exists in
the past and while i don't want to see
the death of either one of those
characters i do absolutely want to see
parts of them die in the series finale
i'd like the part of kim that won't
allow herself to make a decision about
miracle whip to die right off it's not
because it doesn't make sense for her to
punish herself this way because it does
in episode 606 we watched her make this
u-turn that was so on the nose that i
had to fight off the urge of saying she
was choosing the bad choice road with
the unintended consequences that
followed that decision you can see why
she would choose a life where she
doesn't make decisions it's kind of like
you can't fail if you don't try you
can't find yourself on bad choice road
if you don't make any choices i believe
that her going to albuquerque to try to
make things right with cheryl was the
first step in this process and hope that
the transformation is already underway i
said in my last video and during the
stream that if we didn't see kim again i
thought that it would be a fine ending
and still stand by that but we do see a
shot of her in the new promo photos it
doesn't give much away other than to
show us that she does appear but i did
have another thought about her decisions
in the last episode which i'll come back
around to i'd also like to see the gene
takovic part of jimmy die marion has
already taken care of the actual cover
story through her life alert call but
the guy with the mustache who lives in
that omaha apartment does have a
panamanian passport and a band-aid tin
full of diamonds plus about a month or
so ago when his cover was blown by jeff
he was able to arrange a hoover max
extract pressure pro model 60 on the
phone to me hearing him repeating those
words in the finale teaser shows us that
he's thinking of going that route again
he sounds winded which makes sense if
he's on the run and there is some
rustling noise in the background so i
imagine he's made it back to his
apartment after leaving marians and is
essentially doing the same thing he did
back in episode 501 when he called ed
back then he changed his mind and
decided to handle things himself and
this time i really hope that he doesn't
even make it that far because more than
anything what i really want to see is
the death of saul goodman the part of
this character who can sit behind his
desk and tell the woman he loves to have
a nice life before he brushes her off
the persona he built up over the years
to cope with all this hurt that we've
been watching him experience in my mind
that's what i want to say goodbye to
the image in the teaser is of his esteem
presumably in the same ditch on the side
of the road where we last saw it i don't
know if this image is something that
we'll actually see in the finale but i
love the choice of using it in the
teaser either way this is something that
is uniquely jimmy's in the very first
episode we watched as he came into the
parking lot outside the courthouse and
expected him to walk over to the white
cadillac that was conspicuously in the
front of the shot instead he walks up to
this esteem and it was such a great way
to get us to think about how jimmy
mcgill might be different than the saul
goodman we knew from breaking bad the
car in the teaser is a symbol for the
thing we're not sure still exists a
piece of jimmy mcgill at the end of the
last episode when gene didn't stop
marion from pushing the button right
after the words i trusted you seemed to
snap him out of the place where his mind
had taken him we got one of the few
glimpses of jimmy we've seen in the 2010
timeline i'd like to see more of that
and even though he's in survival mode
and soul sensibilities might be useful
for this current situation i'm not sure
any outcome where he retains that way of
dealing with things would feel
satisfying and since i think kim was
right in her assertion that they are
poisonous together and that takes the
idea of them coming back together as a
way to solve jimmy's problems off the
table i find myself wondering what would
she want for jimmy in all those years in
florida thinking about what she loved
and what she gave up and then seeing
where he went with that she knows him
better than anyone else so what would
she want to see happen during the live
stream it came up more than once how she
came clean with cheryl in a very
commendable way but still protected
jimmy by adding the assuming he's still
alive part when she mentions jimmy is
the only remaining witness to what
happened to howard this could be
important for a lot of different reasons
it's not necessarily strange for her to
try to protect him that's something
she's done consistently throughout the
series but what if this is something
different what if what she's doing here
is refusing to make his choice for him i
would say that's also something that she
did throughout the series right up until
she decided to try to help him get past
his ptsd at the end of season 5 by going
after howard the way that backfired and
her general attitude of you don't save
me i saved me which i think compliments
the way she never tried to turn him into
something else all point to her not
wanting to intervene there's also the
call where he mostly attacked her
silence in saw mode towards the end of
that he starts to dial it back and then
a pleading voice keeps saying her name
it's another instance where we almost
can sense jimmy is the one who's talking
and there's a noticeable reaction as
soon as she hears it there was a wall up
while she was listening to him go off
and it comes down briefly in that moment
she does fight off any inclination to
engage with him there which doesn't look
easy and then says she's glad he's alive
and hangs up cutting him off that shows
there's still feelings there and she
watched him bury his after chucking
howard and saw that come back up while
she was signing the divorce papers
across the desk from saul goodman she
knows she can't save him so i imagine
she's hoping for the same thing we're
all hoping for that he's finally able to
look at what not facing these things is
doing to him the episode title is sol
gone and i'm sure that that will have
multiple interpretations but if he can
find a way to confront what he's done
and not default back to being sol as a
way to avoid what needs to happen then
that would be preferable to what he's
been doing since she left how we get
there is an entirely different question
that doesn't feel nearly as important to
me i think the show has made us want to
know how a person goes from being jimmy
to being saul and now that we've seen
how dark that is it's natural to wonder
if there's a way he might redeem himself
turning himself in seems like the most
likely route to get there i mean the
only other options is that he dies and
never does it or he runs away and never
does it this episode is longer than
usual and will likely be over 70 minutes
without the commercial breaks there's a
lot of room for things to happen i can't
even really speculate on how that will
play out it seems like a lot of people
want to see the show return to the
courtroom and get definite answers about
what justice looks like and while i
wouldn't choose that myself
i have faith in the writers so if that's
the way they decided to go then i would
be open to it we still have one more
guaranteed walter white appearance
according to brian cranston people have
been asking what this could be and it's
really hard to say there's a lot of time
and a lot of stuff that happens that it
could be tied to but i've been favoring
one of my early guesses of seeing more
of their time together while they were
in ed's basement waiting to be
disappeared it would connect back to the
episode 405 teaser and could provide a
little more context for gene for people
who never watched breaking bad it should
add something that speaks to why jimmy
is doing what he's doing in this final
episode and as long as it does that i'm
sure it would be compelling having two
actors of that caliber together can
never really be bad so you do try to put
brian cranston and bob odenkirk in a
room together i suppose that's about it
my prediction is that the ending will
all hinge on jimmy coming back out or
not accepting the consequences to clear
the way to become something else or not
the death of purgatory kim cinnabon gene
and please please please give us the
death of saul goodman that's what i want
to see and i can't wait to see what they
put together it would be nice if kim and
jimmy see each other again but depending
on the circumstances i don't think it's
really necessary a chuck flashback and
or some of kim's past would be a nice
bonus but there's really not much that
i'm dying to see outside of what's
happening with these two characters i
can't believe it's the last time we're
doing this but i guess that's a good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you're hoping to see
escape death jail reunited with kim i
just hope he makes the decision because
i know everything they do will make
sense and i'm not expecting to see
things happening to him i'd like to see
him go out on his own terms
where do you think it'll go what do you
think we'll see and what are you going
to do with yourself after it's over
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon